[Musique]
et
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau vip
aujourd'hui nous sommes au stade jean
bouin avec thomas lombard directeur
général du stade français et ancien
joueur de rugby bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes né au chesnay dans les
yvelines
cela vous avez commencé le rugby avant
de rejoindre le rc versailles
le racing club de france puis le stade
français quels souvenirs vous regardez
aujourd'hui du club yvelinois oula ça
remonte loin dans ma mémoire mais c'est
mes premiers c'est mes premiers pas dans
le rugby
gt gt le fist
un homme inspirant mon papa tous les
papas sont évidemment inspire mais qui
avait une vie très riche qui m'avait
d'abord fait faire du tennis puis qui me
racontait toujours ses exploits de
joueur de rugby
donc évidemment par atavisme sans doute
j'ai voulu un jour marcher sur les sur
les pas du paternel et je suis allé
découvrir le rugby au chesnay j'étais
fils unique
je crois que ça m'a fait du bien aussi
de pouvoir partager des trucs avec
d'autres gamins puisque le tennis est un
sport individuel et donc comme sahin
plus j'y suis resté voilà donc c'est ses
premiers contacts avec un sport où la
notion d'équipé très importante c'est
les premiers chocs aussi parce que c'est
un sport de combat
et puis c'est les premiers déplacements
en bus où on quitte la maison on part
pour le week-end
de temps en temps et puis on fait en
fait les 400 coups quoi donc sese seko
décès que des super souvenirs j'en garde
ouais j'en garde beaucoup de beaucoup de
nostalgie parce que c'était aussi une
autre une autre époque fatalement le
rugby était complètement amateur
on pensait pas devenir professionnel
quoi qu'il arrive puis c'est
l'insouciance et la jeunesse donc
c'était c'était chouette d'ailleurs
j'habite toujours à côté du stade comme
quoi peut-être qu'il ya il ya des choses
qui m'ont tellement marqué que j'ai du
mal à m'éloigner tout ça donc vous étiez
au stade français pendant la grosse
période de succès un qu'à titre de
champion de france qu'est ce que ça
représente pour vous est ce que vous
avez des images qui restent des images
oui on en garde toujours quelques images
et j'ai aucune mémoire des matches
rien n'est certain mais mais mes amis
puisque c'est des amis c'est plus des
partenaires ça devient des amis au fil
des années qu'ils se souviennent des
scores des actions des mois pas du tout
et ce que je retiens finalement de
toutes ces années c'est d'essayer des
amitiés fortes et en fait c'est la seule
chose qui a une vraie valeur parce
qu'elle est pérenne et que ça s'oxyde
pas ça disparaît pas à trophées vous
allez le mettre sur la cheminée alors
tous les matins vous allez passer devant
donc au bout d'un moment vous le voyez
plus et puis la mémoire ce elle se perd
avec le temps alors que les amitiés et
perdure donc voilà donc c'est l'occasion
de deux gardes et d'aider des relations
extraordinaires avec d'aider des gens
qui m'ont accompagné que j'ai accompagné
dans ces époques et on traverse le temps
comme ça c'est un peu les souvenirs
d'ancien combattant quand on se reverra
pas trop on n'a pas tout à fait la même
la même notion des choses les mêmes
souvenirs mais
mais à la fin on passe de bons moments
chacun des souvenirs et donc vous avez
rejoint l'équipe de booster dans le
championnat anglais en 2004
vous êtes resté trois saisons quelle
différence il y avait avec un club
français ou dans l'ambiance dans la
façon de jouer ici au stade français on
était dans un an n'était dans un conte
un contexte et un écosystème qui était
complètement je peux pas dire subversif
mais on n'avait pas on avait un stade
mais on n'avait pas de lieu
d'entraînement on avait on avait des
règles mais on les transgresse est on
avait des entraîneurs avec du caractère
on est énormément sur l'affect sur
l'émotion ce qui a marché
et quand vous passez de sale angleterre
avec un système métaux dit rationnels où
tout est minuté cadre et une trappe
professionnaliste ça change
on apprend aussi beaucoup mais à
maîtriser a programmé à répéter la
notion de travail aussi être beaucoup
plus exacerbée qu'en france et puis à la
fin quand on arrête on fait on fait un
mix un peu des deux et on y voit là
peut-être qu'il ya il n'ya pas soit un
modèle français soit un modèle
britannique ou anglo saxons ya
probablement un modèle intermédiaire à
trouver ou
le côté engageant des français autour
d'un projet quand ils sont capables de
se mobiliser a pas de pas d'égal espèce
de rigueur on part souvent de
pragmatisme des anglais a aussi c'est
son intérêt finalement ça fait un mix
d'arriver à le trouver et donc quelques
années avant ça le rugby professionnel
est devenu le rugby pardon est devenu
professionnel en 95
quelle était la différence dans vos
souvenirs
elle est relative
je dirais qu'avant 95 il y avait il y
avait beaucoup de joueurs qui était
d'effrayer on va dire qu'ils
consacraient finalement quand même
beaucoup de temps à leurs pratiques
donc si vous voulez ça a été
officialisée à sion d'un d'un système
qui tendait quand même clairement vers
le professionnalisme
sauf que au niveau des structures les
clubs étaient pas forcément prêts à le
faire il ya une volonté politique pour
10 as raison donc on a été professionnel
très tôt sans être forcément prêts à
l'être voilà on a tâtonné avec avec des
séquences qui ont été abouti d'autres
qu'il aurait été beaucoup moins je crois
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on est on a
trouvé après un peu plus de vingt ans
après la bonne carburation et donc le
temps est passé aujourd'hui vous êtes
directeur du stade français quelles sont
vos fonctions précisément au quotidien à
écouter le stade français c'est un club
qui appartient au docteur hans peter
ville qui est le propriétaire de la
marque capri sun qui a fait
l'acquisition du club en 2017 et qui m'a
conféré donc depuis depuis un an et demi
tous les pouvoirs pour le représenter
évidemment dans la gestion quotidienne
du club et aussi au niveau des instances
de la ligue nationale de rugby donc il
ya c'est une grosse pme le stade
français on a un peu plus de 230
salariés dans lequel évidemment j'inclus
les joueurs donc c'est essayer de 2,2 de
faire fonctionner à la fois la partie
sportive le centre de formation
avoir un oeil sur l'association qui fait
pas partie de la partie professionnelle
mais qui est essentiel dans l'ain dans
un club puisque c'est la mamelle et
aussi toute la partie administrative
puisque on a un stade magnifique que
vous voyez à quel stade jean bouin qu'il
faut faire tourner alors en ce moment on
est évidemment il tourne et tourne à
vide mais on a bon espoir que damien
pistre accueillir du public et puis on
organise tout un tas d'événements des
séminaires des concerts on a une
convention d'occupation du domaine
public était signée ans en 2019 avec la
mairie de paris qui nous permet de jouir
de ce stade
sept jours sur sept presque h24 faire
attention à faire trop de nuisances pour
nous pour nos voisins
voilà donc qui nous donne nous conférer
de liberté d'organiser de tous les
événements possibles dans ce stade et
donc vous l'avez dit ça fait un peu plus
d'un an que vous êtes à ce poste mais
une commune en même temps mais sur quoi
vous avez travaillé la culture la
culture du club ça a été mon premier
ça a été mon premier chantier on est un
club qui a qu'à 130 ans d'existence peu
plus quand je suis arrivé ici est bon je
fréquentais toujours le stade jean bouin
puisque avant de faire ce métier je
travaillais pour qu'elle a plus donc je
venais souvent ici commenté des matches
ce qui m'a frappé c'est l'absence
d'histoire construite on à venir pas en
regardant constamment derrière mais est
inspirant c'est tout c'est ton socle
c'est à force c'est ton inspiration donc
il fallait que ça se passait ils
ressurgissent pas comme un frein ni
comme quelque chose qu'elle est je
dirais billy b les joueurs mais au
contraire comme un sentiment de fierté
donc on a on a ressorti un peu les
cadres et photos les maillots
pour remettre tout ça au goût du jour
dans nos espaces dans notre stade
et puis ensuite créer une culture une
équipe qui gagne c'est la même chose
qu'une entreprise il faut il faut des
salariés qu'ils soient mobilisés autour
d'un projet donc il faut qu'il participe
à la à la construction de ce projet il
faut qu'il y ait une adhésion autour de
ce projet une application pour le
défendre
et puis après on débute et on se lance
dans le grand bain de l'aventuré du
championnat et c'est la même chose pour
les salariés
je ne sais pas de différence entre la
partie professionnelle enfin toutes les
équipes qui composent le stade français
l'équipe administrative pour moi et je
la considère exactement comme une équipe
qui va jouer sur le terrain un match de
90 ans que je joue toutes les semaines
enfin tous les jours amat pour aller
récupérer des marchés chercher de
nouveaux clients mais en tout cas je
dirais que la dynamique de groupe
restait la même c'est une grande équipe
c'est une grande équipe on en entend
toujours sous ça dans l'entreprise on a
même maillot et on a les mêmes valeurs
mais il faut la garder
voilà et le maillot du stade français il
est beau donc quand on quand on a la
chance de le porter il faut en être fier
il faut le montrer et il faut surtout
avoir envie de se battre pour ce maillot
justement sur la fierté donc vous êtes
passé de joueur au stade français vous
avez des consultants vous avez travaillé
ici
maintenant vous êtes directeur général
il ya une fierté d'avoir gravi les
échelons d'avoir changé un peu de voix
même moi j'ai pas je ne vais pas
forcément fait de plan de carrière
je m'étais je m'étais investi dont
j'avais fait des études évidemment
[Musique]
quand le rugby est devenu professionnel
je me suis lancé à corps perdu dans ma
passion quand il s'est arrêté j'ai eu du
mal à m'en séparer donc je suis resté
avec canal+ à rmc
j'ai vécu trés année extraordinaire et
puis voilà cette opportunité s'est
présentée
donc j'essaie de faire de mon mieux j'ai
beaucoup à apprendre
après j'ai un certain nombre de
convictions aussi j'ai légitimité je
pense que ma que le sportif et maman mon
ma modeste carrière de joueur m'a permis
de me permet aujourd'hui de de faire
valoir
après je dirais que voilà l'écueil c'est
de penser qu'on est on a on a raison sur
tout et qu'on sait tous donc il faut
beaucoup écouter les autres il faut
beaucoup les il faut beaucoup les
prochaines et protéger les considérait
surtout dans la période qu'on vit
actuellement et après on peut espérer
avoir quelque chose en retour
il faut une vision et cette vision du
coup donc à l'avenir vous voulez pas
accentuer encore cette culture qu'est ce
que la notion de culture c'est notre
c'est notre stock c'est ce qui nous
permet de mobiliser les gens après vous
pouvez pas leur dire bon on a une
culture on va on va partir dans
l'inconnu
donc il faut un projet il faut que sur
sur 4 5 ans il puisse clairement
identifié nos forces nos faiblesses et
là où on veut aller donc on a un projet
avec 3 3 axes forts le premier c'est
l'éducation
donc ça a trait aux jeunes et à la
formation moi je veux qu'il fasse je
veux qu'il fasse des études en même
temps que que qu'une carrière de joueur
de rugby
il y en a beaucoup qui auront
malheureusement pas la chance de devenir
professionnel en revanche ils vont faire
énormément de sacrifices pour essayer de
l'être
donc il faut qu'on ait un modèle
équilibré et bien d'autres cette notion
de risque aujourd'hui elle est trop
préjudiciable pour le joueur donc il
faut un double projet et sur le projet
doit être équilibrée entre le temps
qu'on consacre à faire des études et le
temps qu'on constatera faire du rugby on
devient pas un meilleur joueur du rugby
nécessairement en passant des heures à
la salle de musculation ou sur le
terrain à répéter les gammes
donc voilà il faut il faut une connexion
avec le monde réel et ce à l'université
le monde scolaire et le monde de
l'éducation est un formidable incubateur
pour c'est pour ces gamins là parce que
quand ils viennent ici ils sont un peu
trop protéger et ils sont un peu hors
sol au niveau des rémunérations etc
donc il faut qu'ils gardent ce lien avec
la avec le monde réel
et a fortiori parce que le plus tard
possible je leur souhaite mais ils
seront à 30 ans 32 33 34 ans 35 ans
peut-être
ils seront par nécessité obligé de se
réinsérer dans la société et les deux
gros les deux les deux autres piliers
pardon s'est rassemblée parce qu'on est
un club populaire qui a fait sous l'ère
de max guazini des choses
extraordinaires qui a rempli le stade de
france à de multiples reprises
donc on est là on a beaucoup de gens qui
aiment le stade français qui connaissent
le stade français maintenant il faut
qu'on avenir qu'on arrive à les faire
revenir au gré des performances
sportives au gré des je parlais tout à
l'heure d'identification pour les
joueurs mais au de l'identification au
projet au club à ce qu'ils dégagent
donc il faut que ça transpire à
l'extérieur et ça c'est très important
pour nous et enfin c'est l'innovation on
est un club qui a toujours été ne pas
dire subversif mais un petit peu
il ya eu un calendrier où les joueurs
ont posé nues il ya eu des matchs
délocalisés ça s'était jamais vu dans le
rugby et même dans le sport de club en
général il ya eu des maillots roses
il ya des maillots de toutes les
couleurs voilà le stade français c'est
c'est ça c'est un club qui a extrêmement
et un président je le répète ma joie
zinic qui a transformé un sport qui
était très très traditionnelle et qui la
fait évoluer vers vers ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui
donc voilà on a sept on a cet héritage
pour nous il faut en profiter
les projets racer on a un projet avec
les aime et c'est ce qui est un centre
de santé qui est dans le stade ici donc
le sport santé aujourd'hui sont des
sujets qui qui parle aux gens le rse je
me répète mais c'est très important
parce que je vous ai expliqué tout à
l'heure avec l'aspect éducatif ça rend
clairement dans les projets restent
toutes les entreprises ont l'obligation
de 2,2 d'abonder là dedans donc on y va
et on va encore au gré des expériences
qu'on fera vivre à nos supporters les
jours de match quand ils seront de
retour
là aussi rester innovant et on espère
que les supporters pourront bientôt
revenir et remplir le tout le monde
l'espère merci beaucoup de mal on m'a
reçue à vous et merci beaucoup à vous
d'avoir suivi cette émission se retrouve
bientôt dans un nouveau vip
[Musique]